hi there here it is day 41 I'm still
fighting my flu here today I'm gonna
talk about some of the sort of I would
say the mechanical almost brain-dead
things that we can do in language
learning to fill in the time to make
sure we put in time to keep us going and
how that helps us notice sounds a bit
confusing let me explain what I mean
today was another marla slow day here we
had good friends coming over for dinner
so i had to go out go shopping my wife
was busy preparing stop virus having to
clean up the house dust and clean and
one thing another day I guess went home
and then I must have spent 45 minutes
cleaning up because my wife she's the
one who spent the day cooking and stuff
and my job is to clean up and when you
have gets us a lot more cleaning up
between pots and pans and dishes and
dessert plates and one thing in another
so cleaning up forty-five minutes
normally in the old days that would have
annoyed me that it was a waste of 45
minutes fact the matter is I'm listening
to Kim Kim Yeon ha I don't understand
most of it I couldn't listen to that as
a full-time occupation but with that in
the back office I'm doing the dishes it
doesn't bother me I understand
twenty thirty percent of it maybe
there's a lot of it is but more than
that I picked up the rhythm of the
language I remember that when I went to
have that meeting with the domani Hill
ball newspaper and I had a very
successful conversation with the editor
when I spoke in Korean and was able to
get my meeting across and I did better
than then if I don't see cases where
I've kind of studied the structures and
trying to go in there and get everything
right so I think there's something about
picking up the rhythm of the language
identifying certain patterns as you're
listening missing some of the key words
not understanding but then you're busy
doing the dishes so that that kind of
works it's kind of brain-dead you're
doing it you're putting in your time
with the language it's not ideal ideal I
would actually go and work the text read
it
save words and phrases go back to this
I might pick up a bit more but even
without that I think it's helping me get
the rhythm of the language also for me
brain-dead is linking linking means
going to the link site getting something
from the library or importing something
and going through and big picking out
come all the words that I don't know
looking them up selecting an appropriate
meaning for them and saving it to my
database I do that so I'll go through a
text and if there's maybe there's 75
words there that are new to me out of
400 words I'll go down I'll go through
and I'll convert those now into words
that I'm supposed to be learning then
when I read on the iPad I can I can read
it because I can find it all the words
but the actual process of linking is
kind of mechanical brain-dead it's
something like it's like if you go to
the gym if you have a routine
you're gonna go lift weights here and
lift weights there you have an
established routine you don't have to
think about it and they just go and do
it and that's kind of I think it's
useful on language trying to have some
of these brain-dead activities just go
and do them you know the routine you go
there a link you finished okay move all
the remaining blue words to known done
go and get a new one so then I can go
through and do three or four or five
with this as I'm selecting these words I
get a bit of a sense of the meaning you
know what's in that article later on if
I read it or listen to it then I'll have
an even better sense so those are the
two kinds of I would say mechanical
brain-dead to just fall into a routine I
do them I can link I don't have to think
that I'm linking I can listen to stuff
that I kind of have don't really
understand I can do that without
thinking but both these activities are
helping me to notice so some of the
words that I heard listening for 45
minutes - Kim Jung ha I noticed certain
things and I'll come across it again in
in some other places and reading or
whatever I don't notice or I'm I'm
saving words that I'm noticing
connections between different words or
in the case of Korean I'm looking up the
character and so all of this activity is
helping me to notice but I doesn't
require a lot of concentration on my
part when I read the text let's say I'm
an iPad or there's some extent if I'm
obviously if I'm looking at some rules
of grammar I have to concentrate to have
to think and sometimes you have that but
it's good to have some of these
mechanical things that you can just do
so that you're still getting in the time
with the language and basically that's
what I did today because I'm still a bit
tired plus I do with my flu plus I had
these other things to do so I still get
in I don't know maybe an hour and a half
to two hours so I'm following below my
my limit tomorrow though I should be
able to get some more done if I feel up
to it and yeah some people suggested
that with my flu I should take a day off
or so but I have said this is a 90 day
challenge so I'm going to stay with it
otherwise they wouldn't what else can I
say
yeah I'm still following the Ukrainian
situation so I did listen to some more
Russian today and it's been snowing all
day in Vancouver for the second or third
day in a row which is kind of unusual so
there you have it and now I'm gonna go
to bed